fabulous secret powers were revealed to
me the day I held Aloft my magic sword
and said feminism in fact is about
hating men and it's been about that
since day one today we're going to take
a look at some videos having to deal
with
um feminism do you think men are
important like for what
always my favorite subject I love
nothing more than that subject and
especially watching videos of people
talking about it I'll start with clip
one this
when I say
I said dude okay every time I was asking
her what she liked and what color she
liked hey what interject and be like I
like that one that's the one that we're
gonna get no no that one she needs that
color no this is the color that I like
you in yep that's what we're getting
[Music]
is your jump gonna finish
well yeah because we certainly know that
women women would never do that right a
woman would never voice her opinion
about what uh her boyfriend or husband
wears that's that's something women
never ever do Hawaiian
oh Barbie those were vintage I myself
would never do that with with my wife I
would never strongly interject with my
opinions about what she's buying not
because I'd be misogynistic to do
something because I just don't care and
like I don't have any opinions about it
and so anytime she tries to get my
opinion it always it goes the other way
where she's trying to extract my opinion
what do you think about between this and
this and this what do you like more I
don't know I I honestly don't know I
have no idea
I don't I don't know what looks better
which one is cheaper buy that one
let me see the price tags oh that one
actually second thought that one's
beautiful and that one right there is
hideous so that's how I decide
everything I can also say
here's what annoys me the most about the
video like this
she didn't say any of that in person
okay so on Tick Tock she's screaming you
know screaming mother effort
she certainly didn't even come close to
say like in person I'm sure she was very
timid and she just said that if this
even happened first of all the story
even happened and then she goes home and
she rips into this guy I can respect
people who are overly confrontational in
person it says 100 guaranteed you
sir if you don't shut up I'm gonna kick
100 of your ass even if I disagree with
their opinion or whatever they're saying
that you have the boldness to just like
speak up in a situation where your
opinion isn't needed but the problem
with all these uh these like hey holes
on Tick Tock is that none of them are
like that in person they're not gonna
say anything
that's what gets me the most all right
let's go to the next one lady so is
there any statistical proof you can give
me that women have it worse than men
women are 47 more likely to suffer
severe injuries in car crashes because
safety features are designed for men
33 000 girls become child Brides every
day
women in rural parts of Africa spend 40
billion hours a year collecting water at
the rate we're going it will take 108
years to close the gender pay Gap as of
right now only six countries give women
equal legal work rights as men and for
every female film character there are
2.24 more men
just your friendly neighborhood feminist
trying to knock down toxic masculinity
doing my best
I mean all that's like do we even have
to dissect it women in rural parts of
Africa are carrying water yeah what are
the men doing in rural parts of Africa
three men on foot will intimidate a
pride of hungry lions and push them off
their kill I will concede that being a
woman in rural Africa as someone who's
been there
[Music]
is not an easy life but uh what what do
you think the men are just like hanging
out in mansions but are they sitting
around playing video games
um no if you live in an impoverished
part of Africa you're gonna spend so
much of your time you know in manual
labor and other kinds of things yeah I
mean really you're spending your time
trying to survive 100 years to close the
gender pay Gap well that's definitely
not the case because as we talked about
last week the gender pay Gap is actually
one penny which is to say that it
doesn't exist that is the margin of
error uh is one penny and so it
effectively doesn't exist but they're
still trying to close it which means
they're actually trying to open it
because they want women to on average
make a lot more than men as reparations
for all the years of alleged uh
patriarchal sexism and all the rest of
it are we back on well clearly someone
in the control room forgot to turn on
expressvpn expressvpn is an app that
encrypts 100 of my online data to
protect it from cyberpunks like the ones
who tried to terrorize my show today
when I use expressvpn my online presence
is anonymized making it difficult for
anyone to track my online activity and
try to shut me down couldn't be easier
to set up you just tap one button on
your phone or computer and you're
protected expressvpn works on all your
devices your phone tablet computer
wherever you are in the world expressvpn
can and will protect you don't let the
cyberpunks who tried to hijack my show
hijack your information visit
expressvpn.com Walsh get three extra
months for you that's exp
ressvpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com Walsh
to learn more
we live in a world that makes fun of
guys who cry but 80 of suicides are guys
okay this one is for dudes and this is a
perfect example why feminism is
beneficial for men so what that means it
is a feminism a lot of you think
feminism is hating men
it's not you are laughing yeah that is
the problem it's about taking down
patriarchians oppressive Norms even
though men are the ones who benefit from
patriarchy the most they're still
victimized to an extent you can think of
it as misogyny being a two-way street
patriarchy tells men they shouldn't be
vulnerable or show emotions it uses
misogyny to label those things as
feminine things so when men get
vulnerable or emotional they're
criticized made fun of told to be a man
not to act like a woman thus talks
against for men because men end up
boiling up their emotions
where to seek help for they don't know
how to deal with these emotions
patriarchy oppresses all of us some more
than others yes but all of us so men
needs to be a feminist also for their
own sake uh he notice with these people
their their criticisms and their
observations about Society have not
changed at all in 40 years and so they
still tell us yeah when a man gets
emotional he's told to stop crying and
be a man be a man and you know don't act
like a woman yeah
[Music]
where are men being told that anymore
I want to go to that place uh but I I
don't see that where is that happening
and no feminism in fact is about hating
men and it has always been in part about
hating men because it's really about
maybe there's a distinction to be drawn
here actually the feminism has always
been about primarily hating the
institution of the family but feminism
has been anti-family anti the nuclear
family and so that's the starting point
and then hating men is an extension of
that and they hate men in particular
when men are in their roles as members
of the family a father husband all that
so they hate men in that context and
it's been about that since day one you
go all the way back to first wave
feminism that allegedly you still hear
these stupid conservatives who say well
feminism has gone off the rails but it
used to be you know it used to be a good
thing uh no go back and read what the
first way feminists wrote and what they
said and they were very anti-family and
anti-man from the very beginning is
always that way on the issue of uh if
men should be more emotional and show
their emotions more this would have at
least been a relevant criticism 40 years
ago and there may have been a time
in American culture
when perhaps there was too much emphasis
on stoicism for men and men were
encouraged to suppress too much and to
be like utterly emotionless that's not
the case at all anymore that's not
that's not what men are encouraged to do
the issue is that men are far too
encouraged to be emotional there's
almost no emphasis on stoicism when
there should be part of being a man and
part of the service that a man can
provide society and especially his
family and his marriage is the ability
to carry burdens with silent dignity and
to carry them with strength and to not
have to always share them with people
around being able to carry a burden on
your own silently Society needs men to
do that
women need men to do that women want men
to do that
but even they can't say that like a
woman would be condemned if she were to
say you know I I find it kind of on
track unattractive when men are like
crying and getting too emotional and
stuff I really don't want that I want to
be the emotional one and uh I don't want
my husband to be as emotional as I am a
woman
cannot say that out loud but that is in
fact how most women feel not a relevant
criticism also false and so it's just
wrong across the board which is what you
always get from feminists and uh I don't
know we made it three videos in which is
more than I thought we would do and
we'll leave it there and I'll talk to
you tomorrow Godspeed
was in my
in mind
[Music]